so I'm hoping that you guys bought stock
in Kleenex this everyone in the theater
just sobbing and it's such an affecting
film I mean it's not just the tears
right there's humor in there as well
can we talk a bit about how humor how
you use humor to help the grieving
process and why it's important to keep
that because life is painful and
hilarious
it's a little like you know James Brooks
I think and in his prime did it best
that how life is everything it's
anything in terms of endearment you know
it's like tragedy but comedy and moments
of levity and it's life is complicated
and it's never just one thing I think
this movie does that very well yeah it
really does did how much of a toll did
plane Cole take on you like how did it
affect you um I I mean it would I was
very sensitive a lot of the time that we
were filming but it it was not um it was
emotionally very open very heavy but it
was not taxing it felt it felt like
I felt like it was the right thing to be
doing I don't know how to explain it
really I kind of just felt like that was
what was supposed to be going on yeah I
don't know how to explain it
hmm did you connect with Dane at all the
actual man or the Ken actual actual man
I met him once about halfway through and
he he couldn't have been kinder and more
supportive I had to separate myself a
little bit from Dane so I didn't worry
if I was how Dane was gonna feel about
the performance because there are some
parts of the Dane character that are
like dorky or like I do some stand-up
comedy where I make Dane not a great
stand-up comedian but I hope that he's
proud when he sees though when he sees
the movie because the way he stepped
into their lives emotionally is pretty
remarkable yeah you know all of us that
saw the film's been talking a lot about
the idea of Dane and a friend like Dane
yeah and like do you have a friend like
that could you be a friend like Dane if
something like that happened to a good
friend of yours do you feel like you
guys could step in that way
you just don't know do you I like to
think I could especially after this
experience I'd like to really think I
could but you know I don't you don't
know until you're put to the test what
do you think I think that I could yeah
yeah what was it like working with
violet in Isabella it was a really
beautiful they were fun and they made
they they brought a lot of light to the
set when especially there were a lot of
kind of heavy heavier moments and even
also just kind of the locations we did a
bit in some hospitals and that was heavy
hit filming in hospitals but then having
these girls running around and like
goofing off all the time it made
everybody kind of goof off all the time
yeah did did it help you sort of not
that you needed help connecting to
Nicole and what she was going through
but did it ground it even more for you
we're watching the scenes where you're
laying there in bed with them and I keep
thinking about my own kids like having
been there with you did that connect
even more for you yeah for sure
I don't have children of my own but I I
I'm a I'm a pretty maternal person I
really really care about people and I
really cared about these girls so much
so yeah having them there basically it
was kind of just like in a split second
everything hurts so much cuz I really
loved them so much what do you want
people to get about not just the idea of
grief but like the fullness of life
from seeing this because like you said
earlier it shows you so much
I feel like this film is a good is a
good perspective on what it is like to
love without abandon even when things
are extremely messy to not shut down or
shut off or close yourself off to other
people or to the people that you love or
your family it's to really lean in to
your life and I think it's so easy now
to be so shut away and disconnected and
this film is the opposite of that yeah
yeah well thanks guys
it was it was beautiful thank you
you